dis donc ça fait un petit moment qu'on
est pas allé sur les forums santé non
allez d'accord on se refait un petit
épisode de DT sissimo je rappelle le
concept pour celles et ceux qui
connaissent pas je vais sur des forum je
sélectionne les questions sur la santé
les plus cruciales ou les plus bizarres
les plus what the fuck et cetera et j'y
réponds ici j'y réponds pour de vrai
sérieux et tout allez c'est parti on y
va Magnetto verge
Serge aujourd'hui on va faire une espèce
de mashup entre DT sisimo donc et ma
série de vidéos sur la santé sexuelle
puisqu'on va faire un DT sissimo spécial
sex ouais non alors on va pas tout biper
hein sinon ça va être pénible par contre
je compte sur vous pour vous abonner
pour liker pour commenter cette vidéo
pour la partager si elle vous plaît
parce que l'algo il aime pas trop ce
genre de sujet vous savez comment ça se
passe allez on va y aller mais juste
avant vous connaissez le petit message
du partenaire de cette vidéo cette vidéo
est sponsorisée par Léo Léo les sextoys
vous vous souvenez ça fait un moment
qu'on travaille ensemble et cette fois
ben comme d'habitude je vais vous parler
d'un de leurs produits et j'aurai un
cadeau pour vous à la fin le Touil du
jour il est très cool à double titre
d'abord parce qu' concerne absolument
tout le monde quel que soit votre genre
ou votre orientation sexuelle et ensuite
parce qu'il vous propose de découvrir
des trucs peut-être nouveau pour vous et
quand je dis il en fait je devrais dire
elle parce que son petit nom c'est Sora
Sora beids beids ça veut dire perle
c'est un toil de stimulation anale avec
une technologie de vibration qui donne
l'impression d'un mouvement comme s'il
allait d'avant en arrière alors qu'en
fait il bouge pas donc en plus d'être
fabriqué dans des matériaux de qualité
comme les autres et d'être
joli il peut vous permettre de découvrir
des trucs que vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas encore tranquillement à
votre rythme progressivement et en plus
il a huit réglages différents bon allez
maintenant trois bonnes nouvelles
d'abord on est en novembre ah bah yes
merci Einstein première nouvelle non
mais attendez parce que en plus bonne
nouvelle il fait nu tout le temps c'est
le mois de la DEP non mais écoutez-moi 2
secondes bonne nouvelle on est en
novembre W je peux en placer une ouais
donc on est en novembre on est en
novembre et en novembre chez Lélo il y a
plein de promos donc hésitez pas à aller
checker leur site vous allez trouver de
quoi surmonter la dé primimes
saisonnière ou faire vos cadeaux de Noël
c'est comme vous voulez ou les deux
d'ailleurs deuxième bonne nouvelle j'ai
un code promo pour vous si vous passez
commande avec le code
dtcbf vous avez 10 % de réduction et
c'est avec les soldes non mais allez-y
c'est pour moi ça me fait plaisir je
vous ai mis le lien dans la description
et puis dernière bonne nouvelle je vous
offre un sorail à beids mais pas ici
pour ça je vous donne rendez-vous sur
Instagram mon compte c'est jmnl
surveillez mes stories je vais vous
expliquer tout ça voilà merci d'avoir
écouter c'est important pour que je
puisse continuer à faire ce genre de
vidéo bon allez cette fois ça y est on y
va c'est parti let's go tu viens
explorer avec
moi est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé à l'une
d'entre vous de voir de la fumée sortir
de votre vagin après un rapport sexuel
après avoir fait l'amour je suis allé
aux toilettes pour évacuer le sperme
j'ai regardé entre mes jambes et au
stupéfaction il y avait de la fumée qui
sortait le vagin qui fume on dirait un
peu un nom de Food truck je trouve hein
mais en fait non c'est un vrai truc j'ai
trouvé plusieurs topiques sur différents
forums qui parlent de ça alors
personnellement je dirais qu'il y a
trois possibilités la première c'est
qu'il pourrait s'agir de personnes qui
font des numéros avec des cigarettes
dans des pingpong show hein je sais pas
si vous connaissez et qui aurait oublié
de recracher bien toute la fumée avant
de redescendre de scène et d'aller aux
toilettes mais je vous cache pas que à
moi aussi ça me paraît un peu niche donc
bon la deuxième c'est que ça pourrait
être des personnes qui se mettent du tal
parce qu'elles ont les fesses irrité que
le tal rentre dans le vagin à la faveur
d'un appel d'air par exemple et que ça
ressort quand elles vont aux toilettes
là encore je pense que ça concerne pas
grand monde donc je suis pas sûr que ce
soit ça quand même ah oui alors au
passage on sait depuis des années
maintenant qu'il faut plus utiliser de
Tal pour les rougeurs aux fesses donc si
vous faites ça ne faites pas ça la
dernière et c'est celle qui me semble le
plus plausible en fait c'est celle que
j'appellerai la théorie du choc
thermique ou du chiot thermique en
l'occurrence dans les deux cas dont on
parle là la production de fumée elle est
constatée au moment de l'expulsion de
fluide corporel dans des toilettes donc
la rencontre entre l'intérieur de notre
corps et l'extérieur notre température
corporelle notre température interne
elle est plus élevée que la température
extérieure bon ça dépend d'où vous vivez
ça dépend de la saison et cetera mais
globalement les deux liquides dont on
parle là l'urine et le sperme ils ont
tous les deux à peu près la même
température on va dire environ 37 deg et
dans les toilettes puisque c'est là que
ça se passe il fait souvent frais hein
c'est pas toujours chauffé par exemple
donc très vraisemblablement cette fumée
c'est de la condensation à cause de la
différence de température comme la buée
qui sort de notre bouche quand il fait
un peu froid vous voyez par contre juste
un truc l'urine on est d'accord elle
sort pas du vagin hein donc dans le
deuxième cas c'est pas le vagin c'est le
ma qui fume ça sonne moins cool ça
ressemble moins un nom de foood truck
mais c'est comme ça qu'on dit j'ai mon
pénis très dur au repos et j'ai un
rétrécissement de la verge j'ai des
problèmes d'érection ça fait déjà 3 mois
avoir le pénis dur au repos et mou en
érection dur quand il est mou et mou
quand il est dur c'est pas banal hein et
c'est vrai que ça doit inquiéter un peu
non mais ça existe vraiment parce que là
bah oui ça existe vraiment et ça
s'appelle le syndrome hard flaxide hard
ça veut dire dur et flaxide bah ça veut
dire flaxide c'est-à-dire flasque mou en
gros enfin en gros non pas en gros
justement vous allez comprendre euh oui
je veux bien parce que là je bon je vous
explique comment ça marche pour avoir
une érection le pénis il a besoin de
trois trucs il a
besoinour non pas forcément mais il a
besoin d'une stimulation physique ou
mentale ou les deux il a besoin de corps
caverneux c'est des tissus de chaque
côté de la verge et il a besoin de corps
spongieux qui est un autre tissu qu'elle
a juste en dessous et puis il a
besoin non toujours pas de sang il a
besoin de sang quand il y a une
stimulation les nerfs ils envoient un
signal électrique jusque dans le pénis
et ça libère du gaz dans les muscles
qu'il y a autour des artères les artères
du pénis du coup elles se détendent et
ça permet à plus de sang d'arrivé au
niveau des corps caverneux qui se
remplissent qui gonflent et qui
deviennent dur un peu comme bah non pas
un peu littéralement comme en fait
justement donc ça gonfle ça devient dur
et ça comprime les petites veines qu'il
y a tout autour du coup c'est un peu
comme si ça faisait Garau ça empêche le
sang de repartir et ça reste gonflé ça
c'est en temps normal dans le cas du
syndrome hard fllaxide les corps
caverneux ils se rétractent et ça ça a
trois conséquences déjà au repos le
pénis il devient plus petit vu que les
tissus se rétractent comme s'il se
repliait sur lui-même ensuite comme tout
ça c'est tout contracté comme c'est les
tissus il sont tout compressés et B
toujours au repos ça devient dur et ça
fait mal avec des sensations un petit
peu bizarres d'engourdissement par
exemple ou de froid et cetera et ensuite
quand il y a une stimulation le sang il
arrive jusqu'au corps cverneux mais
comme ils sont tout rétractés tout
comprimés comme ça bah il a du mal à
rentrer dedans ou en tout cas il a du
mal à y rester donc c'est mou
lesérection elle est pas complète mais
comment mais pourquoi ça fait ça en fait
et ben ça arrive souvent après un
traumatisme du pénis ou du périné soit à
cause d'un rapport sexuel un petit peu
violent si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire soit après une masturbation mais
bien vénère quand même soit après un
accident et dans tous les cas les nerfs
et les artères sont abîés la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ça soigne il y a
différents traitements ça va de la
rééducation au niveau du périné au
soutien psychologique en passant par des
médicaments voir des injections dans les
corps caverneux ou des ondes de choc
pour les aider à se détendre et cetera
et cetera quand je me touche que je
stimule le clitoris je finis toujours
par arriver à l'orgasme plus ou moins
rapidement mais toujours mais je ne
ressens aucun plaisir avant ça comme si
mon [__] était insensible la
pénétration c'est la seule chose qui me
donne du plaisir et encore bon j'ai
raccourci le message qui était un petit
peu long mais mais vous avez compris en
gros cette personne elle raconte qu'elle
arrive à avoir des orgasmes mais qu'elle
ne prend aucun plaisir et qu'elle a
l'impression que son clitoris est mort
c'est ces mots l'insensibilité du
clitoris c'est un truc qui existe ça on
le sait le clitoris à la base c'est le
seul organ dont l'unique job c'est de
donner du plaisir pour ça il est hyper
bien équipé en terme de terminaison
nerveuse vu que c'est ça qui donne les
sensations il est même encore mieux
équipé que ce qu'on croyait parce que
jusqu'à il y a pas longtemps on pensait
qu'il avait à peu près 8000 terminaison
nerveuse alors qu'en fait il y a une
étude récente qui a démontré qu'il en a
plus de
10000 c'est énorme autant vous dire que
c'est hyper sensible mais je pense qu'il
y a une partie d'entre vous qui est déjà
au courant hein et l'autre partie qui
ferait bien de se renseigner conseil
d'amis sauf que oui parfois le clitoris
il est insensible plus ou moins hein et
pour différentes raisons un accident qui
a abîmé les nerfs en question un
accouchement une particularité
anatomique comme le clitoris enfou par
exemple c'estàd que le gland du clitoris
est difficile à atteindre bref il y a
plein de choses qui peuvent expliquer
que le clitoris est soit insensible soit
plus difficile à stimuler soit juste
difficile à trouver à l'extérieur en
tout cas parce que la pénétration
vaginale elle stimule aussi elle stimule
même surtout les structures internes du
clitoris vous vous souvenez un peu de la
forme que ça a
non hop là voilà un clitoris c'est tout
voilà donc cette personne sur le forum
elle nous dit qu'elle arrive à atteindre
l'orgasme par stimulation externe du
clitoris mais sans ressentir de plaisir
et qu'elle ressent du plaisir par
pénétration vaginale c'est-à-dire
potentiellement par stimulation interne
du clitoris ça semble quand même dire
que peut-être non son clitoris est pas
mort comme elle a l'air de le craindre
alors je vais surtout pas me risquer à
donner une réponse comme ça là à partir
d'un message sur un forum évidemment
mais ça me permet quand même d'évoquer
un aspect dont j'ai pas encore parlé les
terminaisons nerveuses elles donnent des
sensations donc elles peuvent permettre
d'atteindre mécaniquement l'orgasme si
elles sont stimulées suffisamment
longtemps mais le plaisir c'est autre
chose dans le plaisir il y a aussi une
dimension psychologique et quand on
n'est pas satisfaite ou satisfait à ce
niveau-là il faut rechercher une cause
physique problème de sensibilité ou
autre mais c'est aussi important d'aller
fouiller du côté psychologique on a déjà
parlé du lâcher prise par exemple qui
est nécessaire pour ressentir du plaisir
mais qui est pas forcément facile pour
tout le monde ça peut être ça mais il y
a aussi plein d'autres blocages
psychologiques qui peuvent nous empêcher
de ressentir du plaisir sans qu'on en
ait forcément conscience donc c'est une
bonne idée d'aller en parler avec une ou
avec un pro psychologue sexologue et
cetera souffler dans le vagin d'une
femme peut la tuer ça sonne comme un
énorme fake hein ça ressemble beaucoup à
une légende urbaine et pourtant si on se
renseigne un peu et ben on se rend
compte que non en tout cas pour être
très clair d'emblé souffler dans un
vagin c'est une mauvaise idée c'est
dangereux voilà ne faites pas ça mais
c'est quoi le risque exactement là et
ben le risque dans un premier temps
c'est de se retrouver avec ce qu'on
appelle un pneumopéritoine c'est-à-dire
avec de l'air dans le ventre si vous
voulez il y a le cas d'une patiente de
24 ans qui s'est présenté aux urgences
avec des grosses grosses douleurs au
niveau du ventre et du thorax qui a été
documenté les médecins l'ont examiné et
en l'interrogeant ils ont fini par
déterminer que les douleurs parce que
c'est pas arrivé qu'une seule fois elles
arrivaient toujours systématiquement 4
heur après un cunilingus et ils ont
compris le problème son partenaire
soufflait très fort dans son vagin
pourquoi il lui envoyait tellement d'air
que ça remontait jusque dans l'utérus
que ça passait par les trompes de fallop
et que ça finissait par se retrouver
dans le péritoine le péritoine c'est une
espèce de sac qu'on a dans l'abdomen et
qui contient tous nos organes qui les
entourent si vous voulez alors pour
cette jeune femme là ça s très bien
terminé pas de problème mais en
cherchant un petit peu plus j'ai
découvert qu'il y avait un vrai risque
d'embolie gazuse surtout chez les femmes
enceintes une embolie gazeuse ça veut
dire qu'il y a de l'air qui passe dans
la circulation sanguine spoiler c'est
pas ouf et il y a plus de risque risque
que ça arrive pendant une grossesse
parce que dans ces cas-là au niveau de
l'utérus il y a ce qu'on appelle le
placenta que vous connaissez sûrement
qui permet à la circulation sanguine de
la mer d'aller alimenter le bébé autour
il y a des membranes qui sont assez
fines et si l'air il est envoyé fort et
s'il y en a beaucoup bah il peut finir
par réussir à passer à travers et à se
retrouver dans le sang de la mer et du
fétus et ça ça peut être mortel pour les
deux j'ai même trouvé un document écrit
par des chercheurs de l'Université de
Florence en Italie qui s'intéresse
spécifiquement à cette question-là et
qui liste un certain nombre de cas
graves voire de cas mortels de cunis
soufflé pendant la grossesse donc si on
veut résumer il y a pas beaucoup
d'études a priori les cas graves sont
quand même plutôt rares mais oui c'est
dangereux de souffler dans le vagin
surtout si on souffre fort surtout s'il
y a une grosse quantité d'air et surtout
donc pendant la grossesse donc en
conclusion je voudrais que vous reteniez
ça un vagin n'est pas un instrument
avant on ne souffle pas dedans si votre
bouche se retrouve dans le secteur il y
a beaucoup mie à faire hein demander
conseils à votre partenaire voilà DTC
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui si vous avez
des questions sur le sujet vous pouvez
me les envoyer à question
dtc@gmail.com ou sur mes réseaux sociaux
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien